good morning John ah the Internet is
pretty great it's weird and economically
and culturally diverse and it's my hobby
and it's my job it's my passion and it's
my friend a lot of the marvelous
weirdness and diversity of the internet
was and is because of a concept called
net neutrality basically the idea that
all the information flowing through the
pipes of the internet has to be treated
the same way which is kind of a new
thing other information distribution
systems never really had that rule which
allowed for people who had money to come
in and control everything but with the
internet whether you're watching like
the most popular television show on TV
right now just watching me in my office
talk with the camera being weirdo are
you looking up net neutrality articles
on Wikipedia all of that information has
to be treated the same the thing is a
lot of companies with a lot of money
don't want it to be this way they would
rather say well if somebody wants to pay
us to deliver their content faster and
slow everybody else down then sure yeah
we want to do that and some companies
want to be able to pay the speed up
their content while their competitors
can't afford to do that so that they can
maintain their stranglehold on the
psyche of the American people the people
who want the Internet to remain neutral
are mostly people we often feel like
people just normal people don't actually
have that much influence on how the
American government is going to get run
out that neutrality this is compounded
by the fact that this is both
technologically and legally complicated
so it's kind of hard to get people on
board with regulations especially when
pro-business people can just say big
government wants to regulate the
awesomest thing ever and that sounds a
little scary we don't want the
government to regulate the Internet I
don't like the idea that we're not
really talking about them regulating the
Internet we're talking about them
regulating the companies that deliver
the Internet so it's really come down to
a vocal and active group of people on
the internet it's not a very big group
of people being the only folks who were
championing net neutrality and honestly
I didn't have a lot of hope that we'd
actually win like that a big win maybe
we'd force a middle course you know look
Tom wheeler of the xec used to work for
the cable industry and they hate net
neutrality and most individual people
don't care about net neutrality they
don't even know what net neutrality is
and practically all of the money being
spent by lobbyists is being spent to
lobby for the destruction of net
neutrality and yet here I sit in a
United States of America where the
Internet has been reclassified as a
public utility giving the government
finally the power to keep the internet
new
trol and the new FCC rules guarantee
that they will do that we won we won
it's almost a foreign idea to me
we won and it's a win against the
lobbyists and against corporate
interests in a situation where there was
no reason for the government to do the
right thing except that it was the right
thing the other thing is that this
really came down to party lines like
there were three Democrats voting on the
FCC and two Republicans and the
Republicans voted against net neutrality
whenever people say like it doesn't
matter both sides of the same side then
something huge like this happens that
would have totally gone the other way if
there had been a different
administration in the White House and
it's huge this is hugely important for
the future of the Internet it's hugely
important for the future of me but it
was dragged out over a long time and it
was complicated it wasn't really sure
when it was gonna actually happen and be
done with it look just not very exciting
but that's how these things happen and I
would feel like a bit of a grapefruit if
I didn't say thank you to all the people
who fought and worked hard to make the
government realize that they needed to
keep the internet neutral also to all
the people in the actual government who
decided to do this despite the fact that
they're going to make a lot of
corporations angry and we know that
those corporations have a lot of power
in America and also I would feel bad if
I didn't just take a little moment to
celebrate and be happy about this thing
that has finally happened after a really
long time of working on it so thank you
everyone this is awesome huzzah John
I'll see you on Tuesday
well Jimmy Carter's found his bed find a
job suddenly you're just an old man
playing a video game is extremely out of
date for ethics I'm just gonna get the
coins in the star nugget this is the
first time Bill Clinton has ever
flirting are you guys fighting over me
right oh thank you Mario
but the princess is in another castle
what is toad talk like what it sounds
like